[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'algérie après
avoir tourné la page de la présidence de
bouteflika
ce pays vient d'élire un nouveau
président qui affiche une véritable
ambition et ses promesses de régler la
crise qui secoue le pays en ce moment
suscite un certain espoir chez les
algériens cependant incarne-t-il un réel
changement
et avec lui quel avenir se dessine pour
l'algérie ce nouveau président algérien
c'est abdel majid tebboune avec +2 58%
des suffrages il arrive en tête du
scrutin présidentiel organisé en
décembre 2019
une victoire assombrie par un taux
d'abstention record plus de 60% des
électeurs ne sont pas venues aux urnes
la tenue du scrutin important pas
apaiser le mouvement de contestation
à peine les résultats annoncés des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
sortent dans la rue pour conspuer le
chef de l'état élu des violences
éclatent dans plusieurs villes du pays
de son côté le nouveau président entend
la main la contestation en annonçant une
série de réformes
un interne à l'international aussi la
stratégie d'abdelmajid tebboune commence
à prendre forme il adopte un ton ferme à
l'égard du président français emmanuel
macron dénonçant une ingérence française
en algérie
quant au maroc voisin il est traité avec
une rudesse qui confèrent parfois à
l'hostilité
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le mouvement de
contestation sans précédent qui sévit en
algérie c'est le blitz appelé irak un
arabe ou mouvement cette contestation
populaire débute le 22 février 2019
en cause l'annoncé de la candidature de
bouteflika un cinquième mandat
présidentiel par centaines de milliers
les algériens de descendre dans la rue
pour crier leur ras-le-bol du système
bouteflika la contestation des bouches à
la fois sur la démission du président et
sur l'annulation du scrutin présidentiel
prévu le 18 avril après l'arrivée du
nouveau président les manifestants ne
montre aucun signe de démobilisation il
réclame le départ de toutes les élites
politiques au pouvoir a exigé une
période de transition à la fin de
laquelle de nouvelles élections
présidentielles serait organisé d'autres
changements de taille voulue par le irak
une nouvelle constitution
une justice indépendante et la liberté
de la presse
les contestataires exigent également la
libération des contestataires détenus
selon la ligue algérienne pour la
défense des droits de l'homme un millier
de personnes auraient été arrêtées dès
février 2010 9 200 d'entre elles
seraient toujours en détention par
ailleurs les affrontements avec la
police ont fait plusieurs morts et des
dizaines de blessés depuis février
dernier l'algérie est le théâtre d'un
mouvement de contestation inédit des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
réclament un changement radical du
système politique fruit de la présidence
d'abdelaziz bouteflika une solution de
fin de crise pourrait s'ouvrir avec
l'élection du nouveau président à peine
élu abdelmajid tebboune se déclare prêt
à dialoguer avec les manifestants afin
d'apaiser les tensions
il annonce un volet de réforme dont la
principale est la révision de la
constitution
or la contestation dont on pas reculer
période de transition une nouvelle
constitution justice indépendante et
liberté de la presse la liste des
revendications est longue
il existe pourtant un sujet qui fait
l'unanimité entre les manifestants et
les autorités
c'est celle des relations avec la france
des pancartes contre emmanuel macron
sont souvent brandie par les
manifestants à peine élu abdelmajid
tebboune adopte un ton ferme à l'égard
du président français qui avait pourtant
appelé au dialogue interne algérien dans
le contexte de ce refroidissement
des relations avec la france l'algérie
pourrait-elle se tourner vers d'autres
partenaires économiques et diplomatiques
comment l'élection du nouveau président
fera t-elle évoluer l'échiquier
politique régional
quels sont les défis qui attendent
tebboune sur le chemin de la sortie de
crise pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons camille sari professeur des
universités et consultant international
monsieur sari bonjour bonjour
abdelmajid tebboune n'était pas le grand
favori de la course se présidentielle
pourquoi le peuple
l'ati choisi en fin de compte et que
signifie le taux d'abstention si élevé
c'est-à-dire de plus de 60%
tout d'abord monsieur tebboune était
quand même moi j'avais la formation deux
mois avant les élections par des amis
bien haut placées en algérie que en
définitive ça serait monsieur tebboune
qui va l'emporter pour la raison
suivante c'est que les soutiens de
monsieur benflis et des autres candidats
laïcs vont s'abstenir ou boycottent les
élections et que monsieur d'été vous il
va compter sur l'électorat traditionnel
un peu religieux mais je dis pas
extrémiste conservateur et que ces gens
là ils sont pas intégrés dans ce qu'on
appelle le irak c'est à dire le
mouvement actuel
quant à haut taux de participation il
est vraiment exagéré
c'est à dire que en réalité à des
chiffres 1 qui qui circulent
je ne je ne suis je ne crois pas que que
ya eu 40 % de votants parce que même
dans les élections législatives
communales pas seulement en algérie dans
toute la région à l'exception de la
tunisie il ya une certaine lassitude
fatalisme en disant de toute façon ça
sert à rien d'aller voter tout est déjà
décidé donc le taux de participation ne
dépassait pas 34% dans les scrutins
précédents je parle pas des
id ancien lit maintenant avec le tout la
mobilisation contre le vote
je pense que on est on est pas vraiment
à 40%
donc le taux d'abstention s'explique par
à la fois l'opposition à ce processus
parce que le mouvement le irak il
demande à ce qu'il y ait de vraies
change de vrais changements structurels
et de vraies élections démocratiques est
libre dans la mesure où les candidats
étaient tous issus du sérail algeria ils
ont tous été ministre premier ministre
de monsieur bouteflika donc et l'armée a
soutenu creux mais monsieur t bone de
pile depuis le départ pensez vous que tu
es boon va essayer de changer
radicalement le système de bouteflika où
on fait du neuf avec du vieux bas
certainement qu'on va faire du neuf avec
du vieux mais on va prendre la
précaution de d'essayer de répondre à
certaines interrogations exigences et
puis revendications de la rue et du
double du mouvement de contestation qui
s'amplifie qui se poursuit devant tous
les vendredis il ya des manifestations
et
par contre là je suis l'actualité de
près en algérie j'ai vu que les chaînes
de télévision ainsi que les organes de
presse officiels parlent beaucoup de
changement de la constitution afin de
diminuer les pouvoirs du président et de
donner plus de pouvoir au parlement de
d'élargir les libertés publiques et de
la presse et puis aussi de de faire
jouer un rôle à la société civile
mais tout ça c'est du déjà vu on a déjà
on a eu déjà la limitation des mandats
présidentiels à deux fois seulement
enfin une fois renouvelable mais deux
mandats maximum et tout le monde sait
que monsieur bouteflika a changé cette
constitution et que on est retombé dans
les travers du passé mais le problème
c'est pas tant des changements vraiment
de forme au même de constitution c'est
l'application c'est la mise en oeuvre je
prends toutes les constitutions du
maghreb avec même la constitution
tunisienne
elle stipule l'égalité en femme mais sur
le l'héritage par exemple droit à
l'héritage
ils disent on peut pas enfreindre les
lois du coran etc
donc c'est un exemple et donc le garçon
il appelait le double de sa soeur mais
donc tout ça c'est pour dire que ce soit
pato la forme les textes les discours
que la sincérité de mettre en place
toutes les promesses et de s'engager
vers un processus démocratique et enfin
monsieur ed boon n'a vraiment pas
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
parce que l'art b sera toujours présente
même plus que par le passé
merci beaucoup monsieur sari nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse tout de suite
mais nous vous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question
l'algérie a donc désormais un nouveau
président en décembre 2019 abdel-majid
tebboune arrive en tête du premier tour
du scrutin présidentiel en remportant
près de 58% des suffrages
seule ombre au tableau seuls 39 9% des
électeurs ont voté
c'est le taux de participation le plus
bas pour un scrutin présidentiel en
algérie le 19 décembre teboul prête
serment lors de la cérémonie officielle
d'investiture
lors de sa campagne il se présente comme
le candidat indépendant
une qualification qui sème le doute chez
beaucoup d'algériens qui a rappelé d'ahl
majid tebboune occupe depuis longtemps
des postes politiques élevé diplômé de
l'école nationale d'administration
d'alger il fait ses premiers pas sur la
scène politique algérienne en 1977 en
tant que secrétaire général de la wilaya
d'adrar
ce n'est qu'avec l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'abhisit ce bouteflika que sa carrière
connaît une ascension fulgurante durant
la présidence de ce dernier tebboune
occupe plusieurs postes ministériels en
mai 2010 est il est nommé premier
ministre mais pour peu de temps
dès août 2017 il est accusé par
bouteflika d'avoir exercé des pressions
sur des hommes d'affaires et il est donc
limogés la presse locale ce site
pourtant sa campagne anticorruption
comme la raison principale du limogeage
elle visait notamment un certain nombre
de grands patrons proches du pouvoir
dès l'annoncé des résultats des dizaines
de milliers d'algériens descendent dans
la rue pour rejeter le chef de l'état
élu des violences éclatent dans
certaines villes du pays parmi les plus
touchés figurent la région de la kabylie
où la population a massivement boycotté
le scrutin
le nouveau président est considéré par
la foule comme un représentant du
système qu'ils veulent à tout prix
démantelé il appelle donc à une période
de transition pilotée par une commission
indépendante
à la fin de cette étape de nouvelles
élections présidentielles se réorganiser
afin de changer profondément le système
de bouteflika à la foule réclame une
pause
tution totalement nouvelle l'autre
exigence de taille et la libération des
contestataires détenus
un millier de manifestants militants
artistes ou journalistes ont été arrêtés
depuis le début de la contestation
en outre la foule réclame une justice
indépendante et la liberté de la presse
à peine déclaré vainqueur le nouveau
président se dit prêt à dialoguer avec
le mouvement de contestation ont appelé
par les algériens
le irak je m'adresse directement aux
irak que j'ai à maintes reprise
qualifiée de béni pour lui tendre la
main afin d'amorcer un dialogue sérieux
au service de l'algérie est seulement de
l'algérie et les premières actions
concrètes ne se font pas attendre fidèle
à ses promesses électorales abdelmajid
tebboune annonce une révision de la
constitution
il propose notamment de limiter le
nombre de mandats présidentiels à deux
et de restreindre les prérogatives du
chef de l'état une réforme qui a pour
objectif d'éviter la concentration du
pouvoir entre les mains d'une seule
personne
la nouvelle constitution garantirait
aussi des libertés personnelles et
collectives les droits de l'homme et la
liberté de la presse le document serait
soumis à un référendum populaire
la nouvelle constitution serait donc le
premier pas vers le renouvellement du
pays qu'il entend réaliser avec son
projet présidentiel
au menu les réformes économiques qui
sont aujourd'hui la priorité absolue
et boum s'engage à augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des algériens en leur assurant
un revenu décent
il promet ainsi de revoir le salaire
minimum à la hausse une mesure qui sera
accompagné d'une exonération fiscale
pour les revenus égaux ou inférieurs à
250 dollars par mois
les charges fiscales seront également
allégé pour les entreprises publiques et
privées selon tes boules cette réforme
permettra de relancer l'économie et de
créer de nouveaux emplois
concernant le volet social le nouveau
président promet de faire de l'accès au
logement une autre priorité les
investissements de taille sont injectés
dans le secteur de la santé les
étudiants eux verront leur bourse
augmente
la seule question qui reste en suspens
est de savoir comment
abdelmajid tebboune va financer tous ses
engagements car l'économie du pays est
actuellement à bout de souffle
la croissance est au ralenti et le
déficit budgétaire plafonnera à 7,2 pour
cent du pib en 2020 selon les prévisions
à cela s'ajoute une forte dépendance du
pays vis-à-vis des hydrocarbures qui
assure 93 % du total de ses exportations
et près de 60% des recettes budgétaires
sur fond de difficultés financières
des centaines d'entreprises cessent leur
activité résultat le chômage ne cesse de
gagner du terrain
les jeunes sont parmi les plus touchées
près d'un tiers d'entre eux n'ont pas de
travail
pourtant tous ces problèmes ne sont pas
nouveaux ils sont apparus avec tout leur
acuité lors du dernier mandat
d'abdelaziz bouteflika
qu'est-ce qui les a déclenchés comment
l'élection du nouveau président
va-t-elle modifier l'échiquier politique
régional
quels sont les premiers pas de thé boon
à l'international la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
depuis le mois de février l'algérie est
le théâtre d'une contestation inédite
contre le pouvoir les manifestants
expriment leur ras-le-bol du système
politique mis en place soit abdelaziz
bouteflika l'ex homme fort du pays
jouissait pourtant d'une forte
popularité tout début de sa présidence
rétrospective en 1999 la guerre civile
entamée huit ans plus tôt bat son plein
en algérie elle se joue surtout entre
l'armée et les divers mouvements
d'islamique le pays est au bord du
gouffre économique
c'est dans ce contexte tendu que des
élections présidentielles ont lieu après
la démission de liamine zeroual
abdelaziz bouteflika candidat
indépendant est connu des milieux
politiques est donné vainqueur le 15
avril 1999
soutenu par l'armée bouteflika souhaite
ouvrir un nouveau chapitre pour
l'algérie mettre un terme aux années de
guerre civile avec les islamistes
appelé aussi décennie noire en juillet
1999 il fait adopter la loi de concorde
civile
l amnistie tous ceux qui ont été
impliqués dans ce conflit ou ont soutenu
les mouvements islamistes
cette loi prévoit également une aide et
des réparations aux familles des
victimes
de leur côté les islamistes doivent se
conformer aux règles du nouveau
gouvernement
progressivement la plupart des groupes
islamistes sont dissous il faudra
attendre 2002 pour que le calme revienne
dès 1992 à 2002 entre 60000 à 150 mille
personnes ont été tuées selon diverses
estimations
cependant l'état d'urgence est tout de
même maintenu et ce jusqu'en 2011
au niveau économique l'algérie connaît
progressivement une amélioration et ce
grâce à la hausse des prix du pétrole
entre 1999 et 2004 le pib passe de 48,6
à 85 3 milliards de dollars cela permet
à bouteflika d'investir massivement dans
la construction d'infrastructures dans
le pays telles que de nouvelles routes
et de nouveaux logements
pourtant l'économie du pays reste
fragile car elle ne repose presque
exclusivement que sur les exportations
des hydrocarbures mais ne développe pas
une industrie propre face aux efforts
entrepris et aux bons résultats
bouteflika est reconduit comme président
en 2004 avec 85 % des voix
son souhait de se maintenir au pouvoir
se fait sentir lorsqu'il décide de
modifier la constitution en 2008 soit un
an avant les présidentielles
désormais il n'y a plus de limite de
mandats présidentiels
bouteflika reste à la tête du pays pour
encore deux mandats supplémentaires
entre 2009 et 2019
alors que le printemps arabe éclater dès
2010 dans le monde arabe le président
bouteflika part fait une image de
stabilité en algérie il a su contenir la
révolte en investissant des programmes
sociaux afin d'améliorer le niveau de
vie des algériens
pourtant l'économie commence vite à
patiner à partir de 2014 alors que le
prix du pétrole baisse à cela s'ajoutent
les problèmes de santé de bouteflika qui
ne s'exprime qu'à de très rares
occasions en public
dès lors les algériens se pose alors la
question de savoir comment bouteflika a
faibli pourra sortir le pays du gouffre
économique tandis que bouteflika annonce
sa candidature à un cinquième mandat
présidentiel un mouvement de
contestation que le connu sous le nom de
irak éclate en février 2019
et rassemble des centaines de milliers
de personnes pendant plusieurs semaines
et sans relâche les gens occupent la rue
dans le pays
face à l'ampleur de la grogne bouteflika
démissionne finalement de son poste de
président le 2 avril 2019
une semaine après c'est abdelkader
bensalah qui est désigné comme président
par intérim
à l'appel des manifestants bensalah
organise des élections présidentielles
anticipées le 13 décembre 2019 c'est
abdel majid tebboune qu'il et remporte
pourtant la mobilisation d'uvira
continue les algériens veulent une
rupture nette avec les élites politiques
sous bouteflika
l'élection du nouveau président
marquera-t-elle un nouveau départ dans
la politique algérienne à
l'international pour voir clairement les
contours de la nouvelle diplomatie
algérienne il faudra a certes ça
attendre un peu pourtant une chose est
déjà sûre les relations entre paris et
alger sont mal partis
j'ai pris note de l'annoncé officielle
que monsieur tebboune a remporté
l'élection présidentielle algérienne dès
le premier tour je souhaite simplement
que ces aspirations exprimées par le
peuple algérien trouvent une réponse
dans le dialogue qui doit s'ouvrir entre
les autorités et la population
cette réaction d' emmanuel macron à
l'élection présidentielle a laissé à
alléger sur sa faim pas un mot de
félicitations et des appels au dialogue
inter algérien le message n'a pas été du
goût d'abdelmadjid tebboune concernant
le président français je ne lui
répondrai pas il est libre de vendre la
marchandise qu'il veut dans son pays
mais moi j'ai été élu par le peuple
algérien et je ne reconnais que le
peuple algérien
un échange qui couronne des mois de
friction pendant sa campagne le nouveau
président avait déjà accusé la france et
ses médias d'ingérence exemple rare de
l'unanimité entre la contestation et le
pouvoir sur le sujet de la france ils
parlent d'une même voix
il faut savoir que des pancartes contre
la france ont parfois brandies par les
manifestants elysée stop halte à
l'ingérence les messages qui résonne en
écho avec les propos des hauts
dignitaires algériens une hostilité qui
n'augure rien de bon pour l'avenir des
relations franco algériennes
pourtant la france n'est pas la seule
mise en cause avec la même vigueur est
la même les limites et c'est aussi le
pignon de bruxelles qui est rejeté par
l'algérie
le mécontentement au monte de tous les
côtés après une résolution du parlement
européen sur l'algérie votée fin
novembre elle dénonce les violations des
droits de l'homme contre les
manifestants et les minorités
religieuses en algérie des réponses
cinglantes jaillissent de tous les côtés
gouvernement et parlement algérien est à
major de l'armée chef d'état par intérim
la classe politique refuse d'accepter le
dicta la rue régie en manifestant contre
l'ingérence sur fond de refroidissement
alger se voit forcé de diversifier sa
diplomatie et c'est du côté de ses
partenaires commerciaux et stratégiques
qu'elles devraient trouver de nouveaux
appuis
il s'agit en premier lieu de la chine
avant même l'indépendance de l'algérie
pékin avait en effet été l'une des
premières capitales à à reconnaître le
gouvernement provisoire
la chine soutient également le fln
algérien pendant la guerre
d'indépendance et après 1962 prête aux
nouvelles et à une assistance financière
et politique quand la chine décide de
faire de l'afrique sa priorité dans les
années 2000 l'algérie est parmi ses
partenaires de prédilection entre 2000
et 2010 est les exportations algériennes
en chine sont multiples et par 60 et la
chine est devenue en 2013 le premier
importateur algérien et van sant la
france de sa première place alger par
ailleurs comptent parmi les plus gros
acheteurs d'armes chinoises dans la
région néanmoins même si ce chiffre est
notable il est loin de rivaliser celui
de ses achats d'armes russes l'algérie
est le troisième plus grand client de la
russie au monde derrière la chine et
l'inde allant des chars aux chasseurs et
sous marins ces achats militaires ont
totalisé 10 milliards entre 96 et 2007
historiquement importante la coopération
militaire entre moscou et alger se
poursuit aujourd'hui dans la pratique
des manoeuvres conjointes sont
régulièrement organisés les dernières
remontant à novembre 2019
la russie veut faire plus étendre la
coopération aux secteurs de l'énergie de
l'industrie et de l'agriculture
entamé il ya quelques années ses efforts
ont déjà pays depuis 2015 les échanges
commerciaux entre moscou et alger ont
été multipliées par deux la relation n'a
pas non plus été rompu
après la démission de bouteflika en
octobre 2019 le président par intérim
abdelkader bensalah rencontre vladimir
poutine lors du forum russie afrique à
sotchi
une position qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité
tout comme l'autre grande constante
régional la brouille entre alger et
rabat même si le roi mohamed 6 vient de
plaider de nouveau pour l'ouverture du
dialogue avec l'algérie cette dernière
fait pour l'instant la sourde oreille
en effet lorsqu'il était candidat
abdelmajid tebboune avait déjà fait
entendre qu'aucun dialogue ne serait
lancé avant des excuses du côté marocain
le président zeroual a fermé la
frontière terrestre après les attentats
de marrakech
il accusait à tort l'algérie d'être
derrière ces attentats
siraba présente des excuses et s'engage
publiquement ne plus avoir ce
comportement on pourra rouvrir la
frontière pour mieux comprendre les
défis et les perspectives du nouveau
pouvoir en algérie nous rejoignons un
nouveau camille sari professeur des
universités et consultant international
monsieur ça arrive parlons maintenant
des défis géopolitiques qui attendent le
nouveau président un coup de froid a
déjà lieu entre macron était boon après
sa victoire aux présidentielles pensez
vous que les relations franco
algériennes seront tumultueuses au cours
des prochaines années ou un mauvais
départ ne signifie t-il en fin de compte
pas grand chose les relations algéro
françaises ont toujours été empreintes
de passion de réaction et de démagogie
aussi de part et d'autre et aussi de la
compréhension d'hostilité de certains
milieux je m'explique
moi je j'étais chargé des relations
économiques entre la france et l'algérie
depuis 1986 et à chaque déclaration d'un
responsable français sur la guerre
d'algérie ou sur la colonisation un
tollé général puis des ruptures et puis
réconciliation mais globalement
globalement il ya un certain pragmatisme
dans la politique française envers
l'algérie et vice versa ce pragmatisme
c'est que il ya impasse historique des
des affinités je dirais culturelle qu'on
le veuille ou non il faut savoir qu'il
ya deux millions de dhs algeria qui sont
soit binationaux algéro français soit
ils résident de en france en tant que
qu'expatrié et puis il ya ces relations
économiques
même s'il faut dire que les relations
économiques qu'ils ont beaucoup baissé
contrairement à ce qu'on dit la france a
été relégué et de loi par la chine la
chine c'est la chine qui domine le
marché de commerce avec les avec
l'algérie et puis les investisseurs
l'algérie aussi a enfin la législation
algérienne et le contexte économique et
sociopolitique algérien ne favorise pas
les investissements étrangers il ya
moins d'investissements français en
algérie que par rapport aux autres
voisins notamment le maroc
et puis pour des raisons objectives
c'est pas des choix c'est vraiment c'est
la rentabilité et la productivité de
l'économie algérienne la désorganisation
il ya quand même des facteurs objectifs
et et puis la france
crotte sur l'algérie pour assurer une
certaine sécurité avec les pays du sahel
vous savez que la france est très
présente au sein des puits au mali au
niger et que elle peut pas de passer
outre à verser donc le sol algeria son
l'accord de l'algérie mais il ya aussi
des biens qui m'a mal acquis ou pape ce
qu il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
littérature là dessus
de la plupart des des haut-gradés de
l'armée des hauts responsables algériens
je dirais dans le passé au rêve ici en
france
et puis la france a un rôle au conseil
de sécurité
donc que ils savent très bien que la
france pourrait voter une résolution par
exemple contre le régime algérien s'il y
a des il ya des morts au niveau des
manifestations ce qui est pas le cas
donc il ya ces relations un peu
compliqué passionnel mais aussi vous
savez le régime algérien a toujours
utilisé la guerre de libération
anticoloniale donc qu'aux antilles
françaises comme argument pour se
maintenir au pouvoir
donc on a en a vu des déclarations
incendiaires de bouteflika contre la
france et moi j'ai bien écouté monsieur
t bone juste après son élection qui a
parlé aussi de ses relations tendues
avec la france mais il y a énormément de
d'hypocrisie dans tout ça les les
relations franco algériennes sont des
relations de de voisinage mais aussi des
relations obligatoire c'est-à-dire il
chaque pays a besoin de l'autre vu les
flux humains etc
merci beaucoup monsieur camille sari je
rappelle vous êtes professeur des
universités et consultant international
merci encore camille sari d'avoir
participé à cette émission et d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage merci
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur herbe
[Musique]